hello and welcome to this announcement
video for today's just 24 live shows we
have the two shows hopefully two shows I
have these computer issues and I
couldn't really do two shows the last
couple of weeks or last two weeks I
think but anyway it scheduled for 4:30
Central Europe in town earlier three
hours earlier than usual the reason is
that today is so st. Louis rapid and
blitz the Blitz portion so I don't want
to get into competition with those guys
so I'm going to start this a little bit
earlier 4:30 for the German show and
6:00 in the evening Central Europe in
time for seven days that's wrong I
clicked the wrong one this one yeah this
one so it's 6:00 in the evening for the
english-language shows and so and this
also the times for the next week because
then we have the sync work up so we have
the earlier shows I hope you manage to
join in you can always participate in
the chat or just 24 even if your unknown
premium if you're a premium you can of
course also play me make sure to join
the links are in the description thank
you